ci siamo su esp fenomeni paranormali
oggi vi faremo vedere dove passeremo il
capodanno siamo tipo in nove e adesso vi
faccio vedere che cazzo di casa è
dall'interno io vi dico solo che
l'entrata di outlast del manicomio di
auto era meno horror di sta roba qua c'è
la musica grazia di dio che se non c'era
quella col cazzo che entravo
perché adesso c'è la musica ma senza
musica questo posto di merda diventa
così
ok ok
bene allora piano di sotto ragazzi
allora questa stanza abbastanza easy
cioè vince un cazzo praticamente a parte
dei cappelli da maria c è uno da
vietnamita però il cappello da
vietnamita per fare le views non me lo
metto fa c'è la cucina tutto molto easy
quanto brutta great action allora io gli
ho visto un sacco di orly dove la gente
muore nella tromba delle scale ed è
uguale a questa uguale allora è tette
questa sa le tette sul quadro non la
posso far vedere che dice il suo ran.de
signore signori la chicca qui si accende
a ci aspetta facciamo l'esorcista 3
diventeremo ricchi
voglio che lo girerà al contrario se
guardano tortura ma cos'è per torturare
le persone dai fingi un esorcismo
mettiti sul letto e fai tutto quello col
colle cole come esci da questo corpo da
esorcismi da insegnarci a fare un
esorcismo bravo sei proprio capace
nola e rosso ma sei pazzo si dormito
quasi tutto anticristo adesso non se ne
accorgerà per niente che la mia come bri
esattamente come prima indicativamente
parlando la casa è questa ma non avete
visto ancora le due chicche riguardo
spiegami che cazzo stai immaginiamo
prima sotto abbiamo pensato perché c'è
il seminterrato di porre l'aspetta team
di quell'atmosfera faccio vedere madonna
il seminterrato regala quanto brutto
sono le candele non accendete la luce
madonna quanto brutta questa chi perde a
tombola stasera dorina equa guarda dove
c'è una lucina roma così ecco addio di
giochi o nulla di schiacciare quella
vedere cos'è sta roba
ma quanto brutto c'è un cadavere l'ha
detto che sta roba che si sta roba
le corna del demonio grazie della casa
allegra che ci hai affittato da lì che
abbiamo deciso di passare il capodanno
fatto che bello eh sì gli ombrelli
addirittura gli ombrelli ma sei tutto
scemo scemo
apri ma tolgo [ __ ] si dice apre e
buio iodio che la cosa più brutta della
vita quante tetro sto seminterrato di
merda e niente ragazzi siamo arrivati
all'ultimo posto tetro perché ce n'è
ancora uno purtroppo ve lo mostriamo
questa cosa questo capannone bellissimo
che che non si sa da dove cazzo è uscito
però è dietro la casa perché c'è un
capannone abbandonato dietro una casa
non lo sappiamo andiamo a scoprirla
quanti horror si possono fare qua
ragazzi o santo di dio vabbè cazzo ma va
ci leghi qualcuno poi trovano sessuali e
vabbè che è fallito se ci sono i lupi
mannari un po sessuati direi
mica tre ste cazzate non ci credo
[Musica]
e cos'è che schifo ai classici c'era la
cimice nel significato per fare il pirla
paranormale
[Musica]
tanti auguri alle feste bella bonanni
2016 ma si toglie basta lontano da
quello guarda come schifo che schifo
cercando di rincorrerli quest'uomo si è
distrutto un viso che fa malissimo
bonato ha appena appurato visto che ora
di dormire e che non ci sono coperte
sufficienti non ci sono letti
sufficienti quindi daniel dr io sto
dormendo in questa specie di letto
improvvisato a poltrona che lui mi ha
lasciato perché un bravo amico e lui
dorme sul divano ma non solo dorme sul
divano e si copre sono una tenda è una a
farvi vedere come d'armi senza tenda a
tutti infreddolito l'uomo è tutto fu
focante tutto bio faccio le poche io
faccio le cose ott
per come ott sono tuttofuoco zoe so fare
le cose perché ho giocato del cuore
metti tutto dentro vicino al fuoco
così si vede bene come 600 euro di
videocamera [ __ ]